We have a response from the Oreo to the
big Bungi video. Let's take a look at
Chud's coverage of that response when
you get the Discord messages. It's not
censored. I will have to try and play
carefully, okay? Let's go. Okay.
Here we go. This is from his Discord.
Nicholas DeOrio thinks this is totally
normal, by the way. Dude, this guy is
such a wretch, man. He's such a
dishonest hack. Look at this, man.
He doesn't But if he does that space,
that's the crazy ego Nick spent hours
on.
Dude, I'm like so nervous. I'm so
nervous. I'm so nervous watching this,
man. I'm so nervous.
There is something inherently funny
about people posting outrageous fetish
content I've never seen before publicly
to their entire Twitter audience.
The point is is you
fat more
Dude.
>> [laughter]
>> It's at 1:18. 1:18 1:19. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Holy
>> [laughter]
>> My heart is like beating on my chest,
dude. I'm like legit on the edge. More
on is that you swept for this. Is that
you downplayed this to oh, this is just
a girl wearing Sketchers. This is the
woman wearing Sketchers. That's the
point, bro. Oh, you're posting weird
fetish content cuz you refuse to engage
with it and you sweep for your mate Tom.
And now he's sat there kind of funny you
posting fetish content. Yeah, like dude,
what is even the point he's trying to
make here? It's such a dude like low
effort deflection. Because you're
downplaying it, you cretinous freak.
Cuz you're downplaying the whole thing
to oh, it's just Sketchers.
>> [snorts]
>> It's just Sketchers. Also, yeah, I don't
buy this idea as well that you never saw
this before. Like, I'm certain Yeah, you
saw some of that 100%. certain. I'm
certain obviously I can't prove what he
has and hasn't seen on the internet.
Without a doubt he saw some of it. But
I'm certain
enough. I'm certain More than Sketchers,
that's for sure. We'll watch those clips
in a second. certain that he would have
seen some coverage of it. He would have
seen a tweet of it. He would have seen
something. He definitely would have seen
something. Oh.
Okay.
So, Chud exclaims
that Nick DeOrio is a
pathetic six-letter F-slur. Okay.
Over this message. I have no issue with
Bungi
and I'm sure the video was very funny.
Which is just like incredibly
curled up in the fetal position.
Just like owned behavior. Okay, he does
it again at 1:21. There's two. Okay.
We're going to 1:23. This dude. I have
no issue with Bungi and I'm sure the
video was very funny.
So, this is him saying
like this this disinterest. This sort of
casual disinterest that he feigns. He's
obviously seething about the fact that
Bungi is
telling him in a video. So, he's got to
do this gay little thing where he goes,
I'm sure it's very funny. Like, tactical
disinterest. When he's obviously deeply
bothered by it. He's going to be deeply
bothered and upset that Big Bungi has
him in this video. That's That's why
he's coming up with these deflections
like, oh, kind of funny you're posting
fetish content on your Twitter. That's
[__] It's obviously a [__]
deflection because he's seething.
without question. That's the start,
guys. That We're not quite at the start,
but we're not going in
chronological order here.
Let's see this.
So, this is sort of the relevant part, I
think, to this to this discussion.
like just
How can you look at this
be like, yeah, I'm up for that. And
then, when it comes out you be with this
be like, no, no, it was nothing to do
with nothing to do with that. Nothing
like that. The entire Instagram is
packed to the [__] rafters with it.
con age player creepy harder on
Instagram. I know what you're thinking.
Big Bungi, you're crazy cuz I watched
Top Sweeper Nicholas DeOrio and he said
that the age play allegation was just
that the girl wore Sketchers on
Instagram. Katie L It's like hot potato.
He did age play with her. No, he did age
play with her. No, he did age play with
her. Wait, but this Ellie person has a
picture on her Instagram where she wore
Sketchers. If the best you got is that
this girl wore
>> [laughter]
>> What? He said so bizarre. THE SWEEPING
FOR no reason. This [__] fat [__]
had the audacity to get mad at me for
saying the big sweep might be on.
And then, he swept this when the time
came. [__] me, dude. Dude. I never saw
this. I never saw this cuz I was away.
And when I came back, obviously, I had
the [__] massive stupid drama with
him over the [__] you know,
This guy got mad at me for saying the
big sweep might be on because loads of
channels weren't [__] talking about
this.
And then he goes and just [__]
sweeps.
And he goes and sweeps that blatantly. A
pair of Sketchers. No, it's not just a
pair of Sketchers, you [__] fat
[__] okay? It's an entire [__]
Instagram profile packed to the rafters.
Packed to the brim with loads of [__]
iconography of childhood. There's baby
pinkies and [__] like that in there.
All right, this is dude. This is
absolutely outrageous that this guy got
that [__] upset over me saying the
big sweep might be on. And this is how
he [__] responds to the age play
stuff when Tom barely talks about it. He
says, oh, hot potato hot potato. Or or
alternatively, maybe people are changing
their story in light of things becoming
public and maybe things are shifting for
that reason rather than it being a
[__] hot potato thing. And then to
[__] act like it's just a pair of
Sketchers.
Oh, dude.
This guy, man. It's unreal, dude.
It's unbelievable. It's
unbelievable that this guy got so
[__] upset over the big sweep might
be on and this is how he's [__]
acting.
Ridiculous. So, that was Chud's reaction
to the uh
newly unearthed sweeping clip of Nick
that Nick is responding to.
Now,
Nick's cope is basically well, it the
criticism doesn't count because
I've looked into it now and my my
ultimate conclusion is still the same.
Doesn't matter if your ultimate
conclusion is still the same. When you
did the coverage, you lied to your
audience because you knew there was more
than just Sketchers. You knew that to be
the case. You lied to your audience and
deflected people when they pointed out
you were lying. You lied to your
audience so that they wouldn't feel like
there was anything worth changing their
mind about. So, all you can say oh, I've
looked into it off stream and I I
figured out that my conclusions are the
same either way. To make your argument
to your audience, to make sure that
people were on your side, you had to lie
in your coverage. You had to lie and
deflect.
So, you swept. So, it stands.
So, either get on stream and defend the
Instagram, defend the Instagram says
there's nothing untoward here and you
know, Tom didn't even meet up with her
or have you whatever [__] you want
to spin about it, whatever lie you want
to say now.
Go for it. Go for it. But until you do
that, you have not in any way contended
with the criticism. Just going into
Discord every time is total [__] [__]
And anyone with above 70 IQ can tell
exactly what you're doing.
So, even even Jar. Even Jar. Um
So, we've got this clip live post about
the big Bungi
video. And this is awesome, guys.
Some gems in here. Seriously, trust me.
Some gems in here.
Um
It's not all good. Some of it's funny.
So, yeah, apparently Nick's had a policy
of not watching Bungi videos. To be
fair, I don't think I've ever seen Nick
watch a Bungi video. I
So, I think people acting like he's just
dodging this one. I think he does have
at least plausible deniability, if not a
valid reason there.
Uh obviously Bungi's video did get taken
down. So, not watching it is a is a
smart move. I I'd censor it. I I had my
editor censor it addish on top of what
Bungi'd already done for the YouTube
release to make sure that the video
stayed up.
So,
it is it is risky. He stopped being a
banned thing. Yeah, that would make
sense. That'd make total sense. So, I
So, I do think that's true.
Yeah, I think they've got They've got an
archive here as well. Show them.
So, here's here's a brilliant comment.
Here's a brilliant comment someone sent
me. I don't think it's worth taking very
seriously when Bungi promotes Queenman's
coverage. When Queenman got his start as
a lolicon mister girl fan DGG er. So,
I'm not a lolicon. I am a mister girl
fan. I was a DGG er. It says that Tom,
Augie, and Nick's opinions are all the
same as two tweets from Tommy C and
summarize all of Nick's problems with
Chud is Nick being mad only because Chud
used the word sweeper.
Well, that's what Nick's claim was.
That's what Nick's claim was is that
Nick said Nick had two basically main
claims, both of which are addressing the
big Bungi video. Is it by calling him a
sweeper
um Chud called his credibility into
question
and swung his audience into him. And
that by saying
if there's nothing to the allegations,
why has Nick canceled the podcast? Um
was a false allegation against Tom. That
by saying that, Chud was saying that Tom
was guilty. Both of those are addressed
in Bungi's video. So, kind of [__]
[__] point to make here.
Also,
this whole thing of
oh, well, Queenman's a mister girl fan.
How can Bungi Bungi says in the video,
he says this almost verbatim. I'm going
to try and quote as close as I can. If
you want to say age play isn't
pedophilia, fine.
But you know who doesn't think that? Any
of these guys. And then he shows all the
comments here. He goes, That's all cuz
that's obviously the point he's making.
Is you can't There are legitimate
arguments either way about how
pedophilic is it pedophilic is it
indicative of a paraphilia or is it
disconnected? Like, what you know,
what's going on there? Bungi have
legitimate arguments on all those all
those questions.
Bungi isn't saying, you know, you can't
have a different take to what I think or
what the commentary guys think. I don't
even think Bungi makes his position
clear on it, to be honest.
Um
He's He's just saying their position is
clear.
If that's their position,
how can they allow this to just sit
about one of their friends? How can they
just
have this question about whether their
friend's a pedophile
sitting in the air?
That's obviously the point that's being
made. So, this is just incredibly
uh low IQ, frankly.
Uh
Chud is being super two-faced in DMs.
Bungi never mentions that. Well, he
wasn't being two-faced in DMs. Well, I
mean, it wasn't even a little bit
two-faced. He was like
doing the placating thing, like trying
to mend
make amends with him. I guess, and being
like not being direct enough
was was the issue. But, you know, I
don't think that's really quite
two-faced. It's not like Chud was saying
some completely different thing
everywhere else. He was saying it his He
had criticisms. He wanted to bring
criticisms.
But, that he didn't feel like he had the
space. But, he needs to be more direct
about the fact that he didn't feel like
he had the space and needed to hash this
out with Nick cuz he just disagreed and
needed to press that earlier because
Nick had already
counted him out. You know, the moment he
might Chud makes that comment on stream
about Nick talking about Ethan Klein,
it's done at that point. And Nick made
that clear at the time.
It It was done at that point. But, Chud
instead instead spends the next year
basically placating, trying to find room
to disagree, try to see like, "Okay, is
there a way we can we can disagree about
this, hash it out, and move on?" But,
there wasn't. There wasn't. Bungi never
mentions Chud is calling Nick a sweeper
for not covering the drama the night it
came out as the stream was ending. Chud
also bitched out and pretend like he was
just talking about pegs after.
That's kind of true. There's some truth
to that. I think I said that at the
time.
I don't know if the British guys all
just feel some national solidarity to
each other. But, they will be
ridiculously bad faith. I don't think
anyone's been bad faith here. Defend
each other. So, literally, I disagree
with you, so you're bad faith.
Good to see that Nicholas Deorio is
fostering a pedophile community. That's
good to see. Obviously, it's been a lot
of dog whistle. It's a dog whistle only
used by
um some of the most reprehensible people
online.
Uh Keemstar makes some argument about
more hypocrisy because about Tom
because Keemstar knows his public record
on lolicons.
You mean I You mean I make
consistent criticisms that align with
my principles and beliefs.
I That must be alien to the clip
lifestyle right there. That must be That
must be totally alien to the clip
lifestyle right there.
It must be a new concept to them. That's
That's okay. I'm
totally happy to introduce them to the
idea of doing that. He's using the word
limey. It's like this is an easy way as
out of outting yourself as having
uh geriatric parents, uh probably Down
syndrome.
Um Didn't Nick like Bungi low? Big Bungi
also like Nick. Sadly, if you're
friendly with Ethan Klein, you're dead
to most of commentary. I So,
I think Nick would contest the idea of
being friendly with Ethan Klein. I think
he'd say, "We We don't even know each
other. We don't even know each other."
Good to see his fans understand it,
though.
Uh I don't think the video was just by
Ethan Klein. The video was about Nick
embarrassing himself over the
Chud stuff, mainly.
I think there's just a certain kind of
commentary YouTubers who just kind of
oppositional such defined as a
contrarian and kind of adopt whatever
position they need to to have a reason
to fight with other commentary
YouTubers. For some reason, they're all
from the UK as well. LiquidSonic, Big
Bungi, Keemstar. I think Chud is
probably the best example, randomly
turning pro ice after being a socialist
for years online right as his views
dropped off. Now, what a dense
paragraph, legit. What a What a dense
paragraph with just so much to think
about here.
So,
first of all, everyone, literally
everyone from the UK is a contrarian.
Every Brit is a contrarian. That's a
very interesting analysis.
Very very interesting analysis.
Couldn't be
Okay.
Call me crazy on this.
But, a lot of this drama
is wrapped up
in people's thoughts on
Israel-Palestine.
And there's quite a significant cultural
divide
between the UK and the US in terms of
attitudes towards Israel. The UK has
much quicker and much
firmer, much more strongly flipped
against Israel.
And as such, you're more likely to see
people from Britain online talking that
way because that's just, you know,
statistically, that's the way the
country is. You know, that's the the way
the culture is. That's the way people
look at things there. More focus on
ideas like international law and stuff
like that. And their partnerships around
the world. The US doesn't give a [__]
The US thinks it's the big I am and can
do whatever the [__] it wants. That's
That's the cultural difference. And so,
you see that reflected in the content
that is all downstream of
Israel-Palestine. Go That couldn't
possibly be it. That couldn't possibly
be it. No, everyone from the UK is
contrarian.
So, that That's the That's the first
part. Chud is probably the best example,
randomly turning pro ice after being a
socialist for years online right as his
views dropped off.
So, I don't even know where to [__]
start with that. Chud has not been like
a
outwardly talking socialist for [__]
years.
He has not spoken like that or about
politics like that for [__] years,
literally years, since before he even
started hanging out with Nick, frankly.
He's been shifting right a long time on
many issues.
Now,
randomly turning pro ice. He didn't turn
pro ice as much as that's funny to us
talking with. He didn't actually turn
pro ice.
He just believed that the Renee Good
shooting was legally justified.
That's what he was arguing. He wasn't
pro ice. He's still anti ice.
Anti anti the Trump enforcement
immigration,
but believed that the Renee Good
shooting was legally justified
even if it was not necessarily morally
justified. Though, I don't know if he
ever made a statement on that. I think
he probably does lean towards it being
morally justified, to be honest, if just
based on the way he spoke about it.
That's what I would think.
After being a socialist
for years online right Okay, we can't
address right as his views dropped off.
Uh no.
Chud's views were doing better before he
started [laughter] defending the Renee
Good shooting. That cost him a lot of
people.
People actually didn't like him
defending the Renee Good shooting.
And then someone corrects him here.
This person just doesn't even know what
they're arguing. That's fine.
Bungi's strength was never really
commentary, TBH. He's good at comedy and
that's done on top of points taken from
other people.
I mean,
the stuff about Nick sweeping was not
taken from anyone. Bungi, I don't even
think that was KF stuff.
Yeah, you can't argue that came from me.
I didn't cover that stuff with Nick.
Don't think it was on KF.
You know, that was just Bungi doing
commentary. Nick's raped on that point.
It's cope. The age play accusations are
weak to begin with. I'm pretty sure the
girls they said he did age play with
came out and said they didn't. The case
against Jeffrey Epstein is overblown.
What was wrong with Is that platform?
[__]
And you got And why did you get seven up
votes for that?
I don't I can't read all this I'm not
going to read all these. They're not
that funny. It's just like
Yeah, people are just going back and
forth about the age play stuff, arguing
about how weak it is or how strong it
is.
I mean, there is a lot of community
there. Obviously, it's not proven.
That's not the point. Not the point of
the video at all. The point is how Nick
chose to cover it.
Didn't really disprove the allegations.
Can't prove a negative. Absolutely fair
point to make.
Um However, people act like he act like
he did prove a negative. That's how
people act.
And Nick actually swept in the coverage.
Again, that's the main point.
[__]
This [__] Oh my god. What's this
guy's name again?
Creepy slime or some [__]
Remember that Bungi's entire gimmick is
intentionally forgoing good faith
criticism for [__] on someone
harder. The only aim is to try to be
funny. I wouldn't waste mental energy
taking this video seriously. Okay, there
are still points made
that follow and like, you know, uh
logically sound,
proven out,
and worth responding to.
Just because he's also making jokes and
being like bad faith in different parts,
doesn't mean they're wrong. Points that
are argued, proven out, and just true.
Surprised no one here is talking about
the Nick sweeping section of the mail.
No one is talking about that. She's just
wearing sketches, bro part. I mean,
sure.
Pretty happy it wasn't let go of if even
if a lot of the videos are [__] posting.
Nick is so lying about that. Everyone
from the beginning was talking about PDF
age play hijinks and screenshots from
his Discord, too.
Pro got [__] scorched. Not going to
lie. They're mouth coping and prices
funny [__] ever.
Saying that Keemstar and Chud are the
best ones to discuss allegations is kind
of wild. I don't even think he knows
what he's talking about.
Allegations specifically only used in my
drama coverage,
for sure.
Nick's coverage uh is just provably um
way worse. You can check out his Skouno
stuff. Compare You know, I haven't
looked at all the Skouno stuff.
But, what I do know
is that Nick swept hard for the first 2
weeks of the drama. And then the moment
one of the people says they were 17,
he's like, "Oh, no. Skouno's done now."
Skouno's done now. When like all the
behaviors were like already proven out.
It's just the moment the the magic
number is spoken. Uh he just He was
like, "Oh, no. It all makes sense now."
Which is like totally embarrassing.
When When like I I I know people like
Chud and Jace Talker were far more
condemning far earlier.
So, adding on to yesterday's Deorio
coverage, okay?
We have some new
uh info coming through. Some new
messages coming through from Deorio.
Not in his Discord this time, instead in
YouTube chats.
So, we see here uh here's Deorio
co-signing uh the pedophile known as
Moral. That's right, guys. Uh he I'm
pointing the wrong way. But,
co-signing the pedophile known as Moral,
um who as you all know
flirted with a flirted with a
17-year-old on Discord.
Um
and
>> [clears throat]
>> here you can see Nick Deorio saying,
"I like how audibly malicious Armenian
Moral is in this clip."
So, I think what's happened here, and I
said I I did say this to Maral last
night, that I don't think honestly
TheOracle would co-sign Maral
if TheOracle
remem- remembered who Maral was.
Because Maral was on uh
TheOracle was on the stream when Maral
got questioned about his moderation of
Turkey Tom's Discord allowing a
pedophile to stay in there or something.
And TheOracle started screeching at
Maral being a pedophile or some [__]
And that's like what got Tom so upset in
that initial confrontation. So,
TheOracle's not only spoken to Maral.
TheOracle's um
already killed Maral once, basically. Uh
one of his nine lives.
Now, the malicious Armenian thing, you
what's happening here is Maral's Discord
account got banned. So, a lot of the
time he uses
a his alt account
now, which is called Armenian Maral.
So, TheOracle's just reading the
username and I guess hasn't totally
connected all the dots of like who Maral
is exactly, I think. And he's like,
"Dude, this Maral guy is awesome."
Because he's he's in like um
he's changed his approach, right? He was
doing like the whole sort of fortress
thing. Obviously, this guy has learned
all of his strategies watching Destiny
content. He was doing the fortress thing
for a while. Now, he's trying to groom
new orbiters. Now, he's trying to groom
new orbiters. So, you see he's going
after he he was already sort of um
testing the water with the Candros, but
you see him going heavy on Dickers. Now,
Maral, big misplay cuz we know Maral is
a pedophile. Uh Dickers uh Maral and
Dickers is a pedophile, too. So,
actually, that's that's two big
misplays. In fact, I'd say Dickers is a
far more heinous and prolific pedophile
than than even Maral is. So, so that's
actually he's two for two on
recruiting pedophiles right now.
Um
Who else is there? Who else is there?
Necandros, who he's testing the water
with already.
Who else is there? Did he say something
about Shamu as well?
I think so, right? Am I right? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Orpheus Orpheus helping me.
Orpheus helping me. Okay, yeah. Yeah, so
Shamu as well. Okay, that's another one.
This is the cope, guys. This is the new
cope. This is the new cope. Right?
Keemstar Casino stop covering Anisa
because she brings up the fact that Andy
Warski was talking to minors on
Snapchat. So, so they they stop covering
Anisa and iDubbz. Nick stops covering
Anisa because she calls him fat and
mocks him a bunch. He sparks the [__]
out on stream, sounds really pissed off,
gets into that rapist voice that he has,
starts uh making derisive sexual sexual
comments about her sounding like he
wants to you know ambush her in a dark
alley.
And so embarrasses himself deeply. She
flames him more. He stops, quits Anisa.
And now, guys, the cope is
>> inoculating all the upcoming talent with
anti-FFW antigens. Nick can't find
someone who isn't already resistant to
my influence.
>> Thank you, Spencer. Thank you for $5,
Spencer. Thank you, Spencer. So, now the
cope is, "Guys, it was actually changing
the content landscape. It was actually
changing the content landscape." No, it
wasn't.
No, it wasn't. This wasn't sucking
anything in. It wasn't stopping drama
happening. Dramas like this were
happening the whole time. That this is
just This is like the internet adjacent
stuff all over again.
It's like the exact same
uh uh
situation, right? It's just some [__]
with intricate relationships going on
Dickers' stream having it all aired out.
And then and then that's it. It's just
like a micro It's one of those micro
dramas. Like a three-day, four-day arc.
Uh and it happens. That happens and has
happened
every month, every other month for the
last two years whether Nick is covering
iDubbz or not.
This is total cope because he had to
stop covering Anisa.
As as such, he's stopped covering most
iDubbz as well cuz he's sort of having
to make it seem like he's not just
avoiding Anisa.
So, he's he's going away from iDubbz and
Anisa. He can't cover H3 anymore because
the lawsuit came out. The Noah Samson
lawsuit came out and no one was on side
with it. So, he can't talk about that
anymore because to give takes that would
allow him to keep a
any sort of respect or audience, he
would have to start siding against Ethan
gradually cuz there's no longevity in
continuing to side with Ethan. He knows
that. He'd have to start gradually
siding against Ethan and that's going to
present a whole host of issues. So, he
can't cover that topic at all anymore,
really. He's not going to cover the Noah
Samson lawsuit. He's not going to be
doing updates on the Noah Samson lawsuit
and all this [__] It's not going to be
happening.
So,
what does he do? Well, obviously, he has
to come up with a reason why, "Oh,
actually, I I need to stop covering
Ethan and and Anisa and all this stuff.
And it's nothing to do with any of the
backlash I'm getting. Nothing to do with
any of the
fighting back from the people involved.
Nothing to do with any of that.
Actually, guys, it's bad for the it's
bad for the space if I'm if I'm covering
too much of this content. Actually,
let's No, that's total cope. It's It was
cope It's cope when Nick says it and it
was cope when Chad was saying it to
Nick.
It's it's cope no matter who's saying
it. It is just [__] It does not
stop other drama from happening. It does
not suck in the coverage. It's a totally
[__] [__] thing to say. All that
[__] has been happening the whole time.
Just because Nick is covering
Anisa and iDubbz does not mean that a
woman is not going to come out with a
TwitLonger about Sakunno or whatever.
That's not how anything works. It's not
how the internet has worked for the last
two years. So, I would say for the last
10 years, just isn't the case. Obviously
not the [__] case. So,
what else have we got? We've got this
quite funny tweet that Maral sent me.
Dickers posting, "Some people seem to
believe I took down my last conversation
with Noah when he invited me onto his
stream. I regularly unlist my stream,
but it's still up stream. But it's still
up. Link below."
And then it's it's a screenshot of just
TheOracle saying
that Dickers took down his stream and
that's an L. So, Dickers has made a
tweet just to be like, "Uh TheOracle
TheOracle
No, actually I actually didn't take it
down. I actually didn't take it down. I
just unlisted. Check your history."
Oh my god. Yeah. Link below. Link below.
Put them in the contraption.
I've had enough. Put them in the
contraption.